In Singapore, the Association of Southeast Asian Nations...
...held a meeting, bringing together diplomats from around the world...
...including China, the U.S., and the EU.
In Zimbabwe, security forces patrol streets and clear out journalists...
...in response to the narrow electoral victory...
...of incumbent President Emmerson Mnangagwa.
In Yemen, at least 20 are dead after an airstrike on a hospital...
...and a fish market in the rebel-held port city of Hodeidah.
Students in Bangladesh launch a massive protest...
...against the country's unregulated private bus industry...
...after two teenagers were killed by a speeding bus in the capital.
Finally from the United States, tech industry giant Apple...
...becomes the first publicly-listed American company...
...valued at 1 trillion dollars.